I think the audience will go on board
this wild fantastic colorful bright
beautiful musically driven emotional
journey with each of these characters
and on top of that will laugh out loud
more than probably any comedy has made
you laugh in the last 10 years it's a
dazzling feat IMAX is the kind of
experience that a film like guardians is
perfect the colors in the movie they're
so rich and the sounds the music is
going to be fantastic
this film is best appreciated in IMAX
screen scale of the movie lends itself
to an IMAX screen so well have whole
other world colorful bag it's dramatic I
mean I feel like it should be seen on
the massive screen it's beautiful you
just want to stand in front of it in awe
just unbelievable
[Music]
having seen there are certain movies
that will play extremely well in IMAX I
do think this is certainly one of them
it's big it's at the big extravaganza
first and foremost I'm a fan and I want
to see a film from the best visual and
audio way possible pieces go siient
appears to go and see you at night so it
visually is just stunning
just maybe sometimes you just want to
hang out on my face to keep ey on an
IMAX screen you know if there's a pause
button you probably want a hit
[Music]
you